halos with the win in game one now 15 to
25 on the season this is game two of the
doubleheader another seven inning
contest
one thing that was impressive with her
kitty last year at the beginning of his
career is he through a lot of strikes
we're
underway at 9 53 central time
and luis ranhipo lines one right to a
led miss diaz so
first out of the year recorded by jose
archite is a line drive caught by the
astros second baseman
mike trout will be the next spatter well
trav was on base
all four times he batted in game one
scored
all four times he got on base next
delivery and on the 3-2 trout draws a
walk
and he is on base again here's anthony
rendon he did not play in game number
one and he lines one to left field
coming on tucker he puts it away
peters makes his 2020 debut
spot his fastball upstairs and finished
with that curveball below the strike
zone he's
got a really good 12-6 break on his
curveball
springer really squared some balls up in
the first game
here's the 1-0 and springer drives this
one pretty deep to left field it sends
back up then still going back at the
wall looking up
see you later a lead-off home run for
george springer
and the astros go up one to nothing
springer's first lead-off home run of
the season
well you can see it coming too as hard
as he's hit the ball the entire time
in this series george is really starting
to crank it up it's kyle tucker who's
driven in five
runs in this series we'll lead things
off for the astros
tucker goes the other way hits it pretty
deep going all the way back his upped in
and he makes
oh no he doesn't make the catch it's in
the corner
tucker will get into second base so a
lead off base runner for the astros here
in the second inning and carlos correa
with a 1-1 count he rips one into left
field tucker had to hold up to make sure
that went through
he'll get over to third base so the
astros with runners on the corners with
nobody out and josh redick batting for
the first time in this double header
that ball is hit well forget about it
josh reddick
deep to right field lefty on lefty again
spiderman a three-run home run and the
astros have jumped out on the angels
four to nothing in game two
josh reddick loving him some southern
california
air plenty of hang time on that one
blasted out to right field
that's that shot of adrenaline i was
looking for
here's the pitch and that's a shot right
up the middle that's going to skip on
through for
base hit so that's the first angel hit
in this game lead off single by the nine
hole hitter briseno
very good against left-handed hitters
held him to a 179 average and a lot of
reason
for that is that changeup after seeing
that swing there's no reason not to go
back to it
there you go you can be the pitching
coach you just kind of think along with
her kitty i mean
hippo wasn't even close to the 1-1 pitch
so why not go back 1-2
chopper towards zaca diaz to correa him
getting into double play and trout is
the batter
down the left field line and that is a
fair ball another extra base hit for
trout
lead off double so two doubles
home run walk walk double here 11
played appearances against the astros in
this series 10
times as reach base 10 for trout
albert walked in the second one of two
free passes issued by the astros
right-hander
that's line to left-center field an rbi
single perhaps more
tucker will cut it off it'll go as a
single angels get on the board so now
the angels have the bases loaded with
one out
barretto will be the next batter chopper
toward the hole correa with a diving
stop gets up fires to first base and got
him what a play by carlos correa
that's the run scores incredible play
reyes saved further damage on a great
play in the hole
phenomenal play in the hole even though
you do give up that run
and you're not able to turn that double
play you're still getting out on a
phenomenal play which could have ended
up being two runs being scored
so brad peacock will be the new pitcher
and he will get ready to make his first
appearance of the season here's the next
pitch
and that one there it's a shot in the
left field and a
catch made there by tucker as he came
sliding
in albert 173 career
rbi versus the astros oh accuse this one
out to right field that is going to fall
in
bring home one upton will score we are
tied up at four a three rbi game for
pujols
i think that's now 175 rpis
for the machine here is george springer
it went out to left field his first time
up also struck out
george sends this one pretty deep to
center field all the way back adele at
the wall
off his glove and gone george springer
two-run home run giving the astros a 6-4
lead george with a multi-home run game
and he just alluded the glove of joe
adele
the tying run now at first base the
winning run and anthony rendon coming to
the plate cascialis ready the first ones
out toward left field toward the corner
the angels have walked off on the
strolls oh
man i hate this double header visiting
stuff
yes winner swing by brett doan three run
home run
and the lead time butchery takes over
here in the bottom of the seventh seven
six halos diaz at the plate payoff
ground ball back
up the middle luis ren heffo has it
there's your win winner winner chicken
dinner the angels pick up the victory